foreign
[Music]
I am working on a course and I kind of
want to introduce some key ideas so we
are going to deviate from my official
speedrun recommendation which is 1e4 and
we're going to play a jababa London I'm
going to kind of give you the general
ropes we're not going to delve too
deeply into the theory but I kind of
want to show you that this is an opening
worth your while
and there's a high probability at kind
of a 16 1700 level that after in the
move Knight 63
there's a high probability that black
will play like E6 or C6 which ultimately
transposes into a French or carocon so
against D5 you can start by playing
Bishop F4 that is the London system but
the more traditional way of entering the
jababa London is to first play the
verisav which is Knight C3
now this move coupled with Knight F6
Bishop G5 is called the verisoff which
is named after a Soviet a master named
Gabriel varasov who played this
extensively I think around the 40s and
50s but sometime in the 20th century he
played the move Bishop to G5 which is
the most natural way of developing the
bishop but if we zoom out for a second
the move Knight C3 violates the most
important principle of D4 openings which
is that you should never block your C
Pawn because the engine that makes a lot
of D4 openings run is of course D4 and
C4 just like when you play one E4 right
what's the equivalent it's like putting
a bishop on D3
before playing D4 right you're blocking
a very important Avenue that allows you
to control a large share of the center
that's kind of what makes this opening
exciting is that you get to violate some
basic rules and take the position into
fresh territory but it works
for several reasons one of which is that
Knight to B5 becomes a very common idea
kind of like the fried liver but
ultimately you're trying to free up the
sea Pawn so Bishop F4 which is the
jababa London system was I wouldn't say
invented uh by any of these players it's
been played for you know for for decades
but these openings aren't always named
after the first person who plays them
but rather often after the person who
who put in the most innovative ideas who
transformed the opening from just an
obscure Backwater system into a
relatively legitimate opening and butter
jibaba Richard report have both done
that I myself have been playing this
system for around seven years really
since 2015. I don't even remember how I
learned about it
but I found it to be
incredibly versatile it's not easy to
play against in Blitz and rapid and I
think at the you know intermediate
player level it's an incredibly good and
practical weapon so Bishop F5 is one of
the most common responses to Bishop F4
the others are E6 there's A6 there's C5
Knight to C6 here by the way blunders
into Knight B5 and you can't defend the
C7 Pawn we'll talk about that after the
game now after Bishop F5 there are two
ways to play this with white the way
that jibava originally played it is to
play the move F3 in this position and
quickly expand on the king side with G4
and H4 talk about crazy hyper modern
systems but recently
um a different approach has been played
by some GMS it looks completely vanilla
it looks like it doesn't pose any danger
and that's exactly why it's so venomous
so here's how it goes you play instead
of F3 the move E3
and the goal is to get this F3 knight uh
the G1 Knight to E5 as soon as possible
once it sits on E5 it exerts very strong
pressure on Black's position and then
you're preparing to play G4 and H4 which
could be absolutely deadly because this
bishop doesn't have a way back through
this diagonal here we go you start with
Knight F3 most players with black they
go Bishop D6
or uh they go Knight bd7 they make a
developing move there we go and now we
stick the Knight on E5 anyway
this is a very dangerous position for
black the best move here is H6 but not a
lot of people know to play this move
because most people don't perceive the
threat and they end up making a mistake
such as castles or most common move as
Knight B8 to D7 just continuing the
development
which is by the way not a bad move
Knight D7 does indirectly defend against
the threat of G4 but we're still able to
exert a lot of pressure on Black's
position in that case castles though is
super common and that does indeed allow
white to play the move G4
now Knight bd7 is not a mistake Min for
example likes to play Knight bd7 here
and G4 as a response is a very common
move
that is wrong because after G4
black plays Bishop takes E5
and once we recapture the bishop black
is able to take on G4 with the Knight
and then the E5 Pawn ends up falling as
well so definitely let's not go G4 here
the way that I like to play this
position is to develop the light script
Bishop to D3 we can also play the move
Bishop to E2 which reinforces the threat
of G4 because then if Bishop E5 D5 the
G4 Pawn is protected twice by the bishop
and the Queen and in fact that will lose
for black because two minor pieces are
hanging at the same time
so there's options here Bishop E2 is the
venomous move Bishop D3 is the more
positional way to approach this what is
the point of Bishop to D3 well the point
is that if black takes on D3 we actually
take with the pawn this is one of the
most typical ideas in the jababa London
to recapture on D3 with the pun
accepting the Double D pawns what is the
purpose of taking back with a pawn
there's two main purposes the first is
to control the E4 and C4 squares but the
main idea is to open up an Avenue for
the queen to get to B3 and exert serious
pressure on Black's Queen side then The
Rook can come out to C1 that is a third
idea once the C pawn moves away the
semi-open C file can be used for white
so Bishop E2 and Bishop D3 are the two
moves but Bishop E2 is kind of a
gimmicky move because if black plays H6
then G4 doesn't carry as much meaning
because the bishop can drop back to age
that one I'd like to play this more
objectively in this game
so as tempting as it is to play Bishop
B2 we're gonna go Bishop D3 and take
back with the pawn and hopefully this
will allow me an opportunity to show
that the jababa London isn't just a
gimmicky opening where you're playing
for tricks and if black sees through
them you know then black is better
that's totally not how it is you can
outplay people positionally in this
opening as well
another very common trap when there are
Bishop on F4 and D6 is the move C5 C5
runs into an easy tactic but a lot of
people miss this tactic who can tell me
what this tactic is after see Bob
perfect timing
perfect timing it's a profit moment and
C6 is even worse than C5
so in fact there are two ways here to
win a pawn now what is it not it's not
Knight takes D7 you might say oh Knight
takes D7 wins a piece because if black
takes the bishop on F4 then white takes
the Knight on F6 with check and
recaptures the bishop and white just has
a knight left but after Knight takes D7
black can recapture with the queen
simply and thereby defending the bishop
on D6 instead what you have to notice is
that the D6 Bishop is unprotected which
means there is a simple Discovery Knight
takes up seven you attack the queen he
pre-moved it because he already saw what
he had missed now we take on D6 this is
of course much better than the other way
to exploit it Knight takes C6 which does
not ruin Black's King side after Knight
C6
ah actually Knight C6 would have been
quite interesting because Queen C7 there
would have run into a further tactic
Knight B5 so Knight takes C6 was
probably also good but this is the more
traditional tactic because this works in
many different types of positions this
would have worked even if black had
played C5
okay now let's finish it off
we need to decide where to put this
bishop well there's a couple of good
ideas here I like the look of Bishop to
E5 just sticking it in the center the
drawback of Bishop to E5 is that black
can move the Knight back to D7 and the
bishop will not be hanging but I'm not
totally sure that we want to give that
Bishop away for a knight on the other
hand that would allow the D4 Pawn to
move into E5 and hit the other Knight so
actually I don't mind that at all
yeah let's go Bishop B5 let's keep it in
the center
where's Bishop to see if Irene Bishop to
A3 was also interesting because it
prevents The Rook from getting to f8 and
it prevents black from easily completing
the manual castling although that's not
really true because black could go Rook
E8 and Tuck the king away on G8 so we're
not going to Checkmate the king here we
should settle in for the Long Haul and
you know try to we were assuming that
black will eventually get his King to G8
that's what I would what I would do with
black hair or Cafe and King G8 we're up
a pawn we have a good position but
there's a lot of technique that we still
need to show so obviously we're going to
Castle quickly here completing our own
development
and here there are again many ways to
convert an advantage like this there
isn't Just One path
uh and this is hard right it's hard to
play accurately in a situation like this
where you're up a pawn and you know
you've got a lot of tempting plans to
choose from
now I think that we should start by
making moves that improve our position
with a relatively low price tag moves
that don't commit to much but open up
new avenues for our pieces I see one
actually I see two such moves on either
side of the board
so let's see if we can name both of them
yeah so one of them is F4 right pushing
the pawn up reinforcing the bishop
potentially preparing to open the f file
and most importantly opening up an
Avenue for The Rook to lift itself let's
say to G3 where it can combine of the
bishop and put pressure on G7 also F4
takes the sting out of the move Knight B
to D7 because in that case we will allow
black to take on E5 recapture with the F
Pawn and open up the f file which can be
used for attack
now is there a downside to playing F4
well you might say it weakens the E3
Pawn but how is black ever going to
attack that pawn he's not Knight G4 is
not possible and even if it was this
Pawn is very very easy to defend so that
is isn't even really a legitimate
drawback Rook C8 instantly I assume our
opponent is preparing C5 which is not
such a scary move I'm not even sure that
opening up the position is in Black's
favor here I don't think it is if we
wanted to be super prophylactic though
we could go B4
we could go before and annoy the heck
out of our opponent and that's precisely
what I want to do let's annoy the heck
out of our opponent
and B4 is a very typical move in in a
queen's gamma decline structures you
might be familiar with the minority
attack that's not the idea of B4 here
we're simply preventing C5
notice the role the indispensable role
played by the D3 Pawn it's controlling
two incredibly important squares C4 and
E4 both of those squares would be
important jumping off points for Black's
Knight without this Pawn so the pawn on
D3 is what makes our position so
waterproof Queen E7 hitting the pawn
okay let's defend it with A3 I still
could not draw that Arrow
of course also possible was Rook B1 but
why delegate the task of defending the
pawn to The Rook when it can be easily
done by a pawn that's one of the key
positional tenets I've shared is that in
general a task should be accomplished by
the lowest value piece so leave the
higher value pieces free to do more
important things
that's why pawns should normally be
defended with pawns when possible Queen
F7 okay
so now I think that we should continue
improving our situation on the king side
so F5 here is a very committal move but
it's interesting F5 takes takes and then
we could bring our Queen to F3 and we
could try to quickly get control of the
f file but I'm not convinced that we
will get control of the f file if we
look at it F5 EF Rook F5 black can put
the queen on G6
and if we play Queen F3 the Knight can
drop back to D7 then the bishop is under
pressure and we run the risk of sort of
collapsing in the center so I don't see
the need to rush F5 the movie 4 looks
good but I also don't see the need to
play E4 what does that move really
accomplish what if black does nothing
after E4 right how are we going to
proceed well you could say we'll play F5
then but that enters into a lot of
tactics and I'm not really sure that I
want to do that given how nice our
position is
so instead let's continue improving our
position we already have several ways of
doing that we can play Rook F3 we can
play Queen F3 and get the queen over to
the king side which I really really like
the look of
but let's play according to how we
um initially
devised which is Rook F3
preparing for the king side attack and
not worrying that this bishop is going
to be targeted because it's so well
defended
yeah of course we could also play on The
Queen side like A4 and stuff but the
king sides really where it's at okay
Knight D7 this does not contain a threat
but that doesn't mean we should fall
asleep because
I assume that our opponent is going to
move the queen and then take the bishop
on E5 so what I really would like to do
here is involve this last Rook right
rather than completing the Rook lift
which would allow Knight takes C5 I
think we should begin by involving this
rook and putting it on F1 because I am
anticipating a battle for control of the
f-file right the battle for Winterfell
is going to happen eventually
let's bring Jon Snow over to F1
we need to we need to rotate to 82
possible but while we're at it let's put
the queen on a nicer Central Square also
good was Rook A2 and Rook F2 although I
like it less because on F2 The Rook
would be susceptible to a potential
Knight to G4 right you want to put your
pieces in such a way that they're least
vulnerable to moves that could
potentially be annoying
whoa
fortunately there was nothing in that
so again why is Knight takes C5 not
possible because we recapture with the F
Pawn hitting the Knight and the Knight
cannot move because
uh the queen is pinned
what are our next few moves likely to be
well Rook af1
then we can complete the Rook lifts now
that we've got a rook that will watch
over the f-file
and we're just going to continue
accumulating pieces on the king side
nothing happens fast in these types of
positions you have to accumulate
gradually and eventually something is
going to give or you're gonna have to be
the one to open up the position
but at this level more often than not
people they lose their patience when
they're under this much pressure as
we've seen time and time again we just
have to be alert in in case the blunder
arrives at our doorstep unexpectedly no
this is not completely lost even at my
level no this is far from completely
lost I would not be confident here that
I could beat Magnus like not even close
probably if I had this against Magnus I
would win
in a classical game I don't know it's
hard for me to say but maybe like half
of the time and then 25 would be a draw
but I would definitely lose like a
certain share of games from this
position we're just up upon it's not the
game is not over King h8
now we I don't see a reason for us not
to play Rook F1
let's proceed according to plan and
already F5 looks quite a bit more
appealing now that we have the beef
sitting on the f-file
no I've never played Magnuson classical
sadly maybe I will
where is Hodor and all this yes
hold the door
Knight G4
okay so that's an interesting move
our opponent really trying to go after
this bishop
there's a cool tactic here that I'll
show after the game We're not gonna play
it though
now there's a choice here we could leave
the bishop on E5 but we actually do have
the option of playing Bishop to D6
because on D6 the bishop is surprisingly
safe it's in amongst the trees but it's
really hard to attack and I don't want
to give this bishop away for no reason I
don't see a reason that we shouldn't
Play Bishop D6 here moreover it chases
The Rook out of f8 which makes the
possibility of F5 more tempting and the
bishop could always return to E5 we have
home base so it's not like the bishop
runs the risk of getting trapped Rook at
Faith yeah Bishop G7 is the is the
gimmicky move that I saw but we'll
analyze that after the game
now F5 here is a super tempting move the
problem is that black can keep the f
file closed with E5
and in that position oh we have a cool
tactic let me think about this for a
second
it's a cool tactic there
that might work
it actually very well might oh
okay this is unfortunately too tempting
not to play yeah let's go F5
and the logic of this move should be
evident include I mean H3 is what I
would play at my level I would play H3
and then I would probably play F5
so maybe I should do that given that in
the speeder and I try to play exactly
like I would in a classical game
let me think about this for a second
also good by the way is Rook to G3 same
idea chase the Knight out of G4
but then maybe the Knight can drop back
to like H6 and F5
whereas after H3 Knight H6 we can lock
the night out with G4
we can also play E4 good move
maybe E4 is the best move I don't know
you know what let's leave the craziness
for another day and let's play H3
you know important thing here is to
emphasize good habits I'll show you some
of my analysis and Thoughts with F5
after the game but it gets needlessly
Tactical
and that's not how I recommend people
play
yeah all of the pawn breaks are
controlled by white like E4 F5 Hess
really points this out beside the
controls the pawn breaks has a big
Advantage here white controls all of the
pawn breaks okay Knight H6 is important
not to fall asleep here because Knight
F5 is an annoying move then I could
start massaging some of these dark
squares there are two ways to prevent
Knight F5 both of them are really good
we can play G4 or we can play E4 but I
like E4
because it doesn't weaken the king side
but more importantly I want to leave the
G file open for my Rook the drawback of
playing G4 is that that Rook on F3 is
like hey what about me and it will be
blocked by pawns basically forcing it
into the into a role as a preparer of
upon break whereas The Rook could
potentially win the game with a role as
a direct attacker on the G7 Pawn
yeah old man Dania prevailed that time
I mean the situation is becoming more
and more dire for black he's getting
more and more cramped
and we haven't made any concessions to
cause that so things are going the right
direction
so given the option I would not play E5
here that would be counter productive
because it would reopen it would reopen
via five square for black snide and then
D4 would be hanging and D6 would be
under attack so definitely not E5 unless
we can some supplement it with the move
G4 if our Pawn was on G4 then yes E5
would be a legitimate idea but here E5
would be a very instructive mistake
because of Knight F5 as tempting as it
is you know to push the pawn
now instead I think we should play a
very measured move remember that when
the bishop came to D6 it's not really
taking a big risk what's the like you
know it's not no frills not a fancy move
but I think it's the best move just
Bishop back to E5
just bring it back to home Mason
pressure G7 also we're protecting the D4
Pawn so D takes E4 is no longer scary
because we can just recapture with the
pawn and that rectifies our Pawn
structure
what if black brings the Knight back to
D7 well then we first of all then
already we can consider F5 but the
Knight takes E5 is not a threat it was
never a threat because we can recapture
with the F Pawn remember why did we play
Bishop D6 in the first place it was to
force the Rook off of the f-file now
after Knight D7 Knight takes E5 we we
dominate the f-file because we've got
two Rooks there and Black's Queen is
gonna have to move away
so it's not like we're repeating moves
we actually made progress in comparison
to the other instances in which black
could have taken the bishop Knight G6
okay this gives us a unique opportunity
that would not be as available after
Knight to D7 which is the move F5
here F5 is much more attractive to me
because it comes with tempo
and it forces Black's hand and if black
is not careful the pawn could move to F6
now there's some calculation that has to
be done F5 e takes F5 e takes F5 Knight
H4 Forks the rook and the pawn but after
Rook F4 Knight takes F5 we have the
obvious move G4 and that wins the Knight
and that's all the calculating we have
to do let's go for it again very low
risk it's all of our pieces are in
perfect square so it's not like things
could go that badly here for white
everything's defended now we're just
crushing him on the king side
Knight takes E5 D takes E5 and you can
see that our Pawn structure begins to
coalesce into something
uh really intimidating
play as he takes F5 we recapture with
the pawn
I'm expecting that H4 because it's
attempting move
there was an interesting detail that I
missed we'll check this with the engine
because
there was the possibility of playing d e
d e and then 95 and queen C7 crazy idea
we'll we'll check it afterward
so maybe F5 was a tactical error but
we'll see yeah we're just strangling
black
so if Knight E5 then we played de and
our pawns should decide the game also
the Knight on H6 is totally out of the
game which is really helping us putting
that pawn on H3 was a great decision
because it closes off the night's last
remaining activation route
but the thing about the boa constrictor
method is you have to eventually you
have to act like you can build up for so
long but eventually you have to
transform that Advantage into something
more concrete and choosing that moment
is a very very hard uh skill and it's
not a skill that I've mastered
or that you can never really Master
there are some players who are
absolute masters of that skill like
Carlson he's the ultimate boa
constrictor
but if you look at his games even his
Blitz Games he doesn't squeeze you to
death eventually he launches an attacker
he uses his positional advantages to
transform it into something more
Tactical
kramnik karpov lots of players that you
can look at for more inspiration on this
style karpov was the original boa
constrictor I think that's
what the nickname was applied toward
initially
yeah ding a lot of players nowadays have
that boa constrictor type of style
okay so black is thinking if he drops
the Knight back then we definitely F6
ends the game immediately
it ends the game immediately
okay Knight H4 cool
so by the way F6 even here would not be
totally out of the question
unfortunately Knight takes F3 is a check
otherwise we would play FG that would be
crushing so again
let's be careful here for just a second
I saw something a little bit annoying
about this for me yeah let's go work F4
okay let's start with Rook F4
there was one thing that I missed but it
doesn't change the evaluation it might
just make the winning process a little
bit more arduous
yeah we might have to
change our plan either there's a detail
that I missed which is that after Knight
takes F5 G4 black has this very weird
move Queen G6 which I will admit I
completely missed we're gonna play G4
anyway and he finds it nice job
now we can play Rook takes F5 and get
two pieces for a rook and that is
winning there's no question in my mind
that that is completely winning
but let's see if we can find something
more accurate
Queen F2 is interesting now King H2 is
the move I want to play but of course
the point is that the Knight can now
move the queen is no longer pinned so
Knight D6 oh but then we have a very
cool tactic
okay we gotta do it
King H2 97 Rook F6 is the sexy move but
then black has Queen G5
graph seven yeah let's do it let's try
it let's try it let's see where it leads
this is fun of course Rook takes F5
gives you two pieces for a rook but more
importantly your Bishop is a monster in
the resulting position so that should be
a technical win but it would not have
been easy this I think could lead to a
faster win if we stay tactically
accurate
lots of ideas here to unpack but let's
see where black puts the Knight because
everything changes based on where our
opponent brings his Knight I'm expecting
Knight D6
I'm expecting Knight to D6
but we'll see
yeah the bishop on E5 is just a complete
badass
this bishop is is hopefully going to win
us the game if we're accurate
so what are the options for black well
there's three options right there's
Knight to H4 Knight E7 and Knight D6 not
moving the Knight is not an option
because at this point we're threatening
to capture that's why we played King H2
for newer players you couldn't take the
Knight here because the g-pawn was
pinned to the king
so the easiest way is to just move the
king away
but I'm I believe that the tactics are
going to work in our favor because the
pieces are better placed that increases
does not guarantee that tactics are
going to work in your favor but it
greatly increases the chance of that
being the case
I think the best move is Knight E7 and
I'll explain the reason why afterward in
more depth
and he's found it very nice 97 very nice
but nothing we can't deal with I
calculated this and I thought I came up
with a really really cool sequence of
moves so the tactic that I've been
making the whole fuss about is what what
is the Tactical move that I've already
said it so if you've been listening
carefully you should
you should have noticed it it's not no
it's not Bishop takes G7 that would be
as simply a blunder because Queen takes
G7 and that protects dark now the move
is Rook to F6 that's the move that got
me excited
but the idea is simple after GF you
don't play Bishop takes F6 that's check
itis you instead play Rook takes F6 and
that sets up Unstoppable threats it
attacks the queen A and B well it
threatens Rook f8 mate that's a double
check and a mate I haven't even
calculated that but I'm positive that
that has to be winning positive probably
probably GF Bishop F6 check is not
that bad for white but I don't think
it's convincing at all
maybe also winning but Rook F6 looks
totally winning unless I'm missing
something big there
now if black doesn't take the Rook then
that means he has two moves Queen to E8
is the move I hope he plays because then
we can capture the Knight again our
Bishop prevails because the G Pawn is
pinned the move that it got me
frustrated was Queen to G5 why Queen G5
because then Rook takes H6 doesn't seem
to make as much sense because if Queen
takes H6 but if you extend that line one
more move I think we do have a winning
move in that position which is what
never mind it was uh Rook F7 okay
clearly our opponent has found something
here I wonder what it is there is a move
that I missed let's see if he plays it I
don't think this move changes the
evaluation though I think it just makes
the winning process
more more difficult
yeah I did miss I did miss I think the
best defense here so I've I've been
sloppy tactically this game
but still a lot of cool ideas
yeah no he doesn't give up I have to
give Jack some credit
he's been defending very very well
but we are winning objectively no doubt
about that and he found the move King G8
for some reason I just didn't realize
that this gets out of the discovery now
we obviously have to take the queen and
Knight G6 black is surviving we have a
queen and a pawn for two Rooks so
materially our advantage is far from
overwhelming the reason I think white is
winning is because the king is
incredibly weak
and the Knights are very poorly placed
especially the night on H6 which just
doesn't have a lot of active prospects
but what we have to do here is reset and
figure out a way to put pressure on the
king side
what we're going to do here to start is
drop the bishop back which may seem very
counter-intuitive to you right didn't I
I've been making this whole fuss about
the bishop on E5 now black was
threatening to trade it and I definitely
don't want to give that Bishop away
maybe one day it'll be able to move back
to E5 so we're leaving the bishop and
putting it in a safe square but there is
a secondary idea of putting it
specifically on G3 let's move the queen
over to D2
which is that after the H6 Knight is
chased away we can set our Pawns in
motion and I feel like the pawns might
decide the game I'm actually just going
to play this instantly to keep pressure
on my opponent's clock which is a
legitimate strategy by the way H4
and I feel like we're getting the upper
hand here but
I still see that black is an incredibly
Advanced tactical idea that
can be used
in response we'll see what our opponent
comes up with
what is the purpose of H4 well we're
simply trying to drive the knights off
of their posts to open up the king even
further and then the pawns can be used
in advance to H6 maybe at some point
also H5 opens up new prospects for the
bishop
on H4
oh it just feels like
the ball the ball is rolling rookie six
okay
so I don't see a compelling reason for
us not to play H5 quickly which is what
I'm going to do
and also it's nice that the H funds are
controlling some key squares on the king
side
okay but our opponent I mean I have to
say is is out playing me in the Tactical
phase of the game it's just that we were
so overwhelmingly better
that I still think we're winning Knight
f8 now we need to bring in the reserves
I don't think that we should play G5
here I think that would be premature
because the pawn is never going to get
to G6 what piece could be doing more
than it's doing
yeah I mean it's the night right it's
definitely the night it's just sitting
there and it really only has one Pathway
to joining the game which is 92 and
Knight F4 in fact we should play it
immediately because black will double
Rooks and that will slice off the
knights route to F4 moreover we wouldn't
have been able to even play Knight D1
then because of rookie 2 winning the
queen so 92 is a very time sensitive
move
we need to get this Knight over to the
king side so it can help the attack
Knight F4 our opponent playing
phenomenally here
phenomenally
black even has the incredibly fancy move
Knight to G5 threatening a fork on F3 of
course I didn't see that but we can
slide our King over in that case to G2
which is where it wants to be anyway the
king wants to be on G2 here to control
the F3 score he doesn't do it goes back
to E7
okay we need to find ways to keep our
foot on the gas pedal here I think we
should start with the move Bishop H4 I
don't see a downside
to improving our Bishop a little bit
here first now notice that rookie 2 is
not possible the Knight defends
that square so that is not a fork
in fact I think black has only one
available move here although it is a
good move it's not an easy move to fight
against
rookie three rookie 3 is forced but then
I think I see something really cool that
we could do our opponent taking a long
time to find or actually I mean I guess
Rook D7 is possible but somehow in my
mind that gets The Rook off of the
e-file which relieves the burden on our
position quite a bit
but we don't have to worry as much then
about various Shenanigans and we our
pieces get more freedom so Rogue D7
would be some sort of a victory rookie
three okay I think I find a way found a
way to get into a good position here let
me think for a moment this is getting
very very close
so of course we have a draw we can play
Bishop F2 and Bishop H4 and Chase The
Rook around to uh
you know to Infinity
but I think what we should do here well
it doesn't really work though
damn
we could play G5 but I think we should
start by improving our position with
King to jitsu
I think we should start by improving our
position with King tujitsu
yeah there is 96 here actually 96 might
be very annoying yeah 96 is probably a
good move now we want to play King F2
and the idea is to actually give the
queen back for the Rook
okay Knight D7
okay that is a good move so we can play
Bishop F2 rookie seven
we have a repetition in our pocket but
we don't want to draw
King F2 I just realized there's a
ridiculous refutation if we play King F2
and try to give the queen back for the
two Rooks black has Knight F7 to H6 I'll
show you after the game why that's so
bad for white but that checks that out I
think we should play G5
I think the time has come
for us to play G5
I think we should play G5 I think we
should push
I think we should push now what is the
idea of G5 well we're trying to go G6
and tear him apart on the king side
potentially
but there's a secondary idea which is to
get
control of the H6 square and reinforce
the threat of King to F2
King to F2 is now a big threat because
if the Rook goes back to E7 we then have
G6 that's a devastating move it opens up
an attack on The Rook as well as an
attack on the Knight Knight D6 good move
okay
this is getting serious I think we
should play Bishop F2 and Chase The Rook
away for starters I'm tired of this Rook
let's get it let's get it out of there
let's get it out of there I still think
we're winning but I think we need to be
very very accurate
okay
so now I'm asking myself again the
question which pieces could be doing
more than they are doing and the
response I'm getting is the queen right
the queen is just kind of staring at a
bunch of our own pieces so what we're
going to do here is Queen D1 and queen
G4 simply reinforcing increasing the
attack these are simple moves and these
are moves that can be played relatively
quickly I'm also trying to put pressure
on Black's clock he's got 90 seconds he
is taking a lot of time here each
defensive move is okay he's accelerating
his space okay we can complete our
maneuver with Queen G4
I think this can be played instantly
and notice that Knight E3 check does not
work because we play Bishop takes E3
Rook takes C3 and queen takes Knight so
I'm also eyeing the Knight on D7
and the time continues to creep down for
our opponent
he's taking over 15 seconds per move
Knight G7 okay we're making progress
here
I think white is winning this show okay
obviously what I'm seeing Chad and I'm
very disappointed
because every time somebody finds three
good moves like everybody jumps to
conclusions 100 not getting suspicious
Vibes at all just significantly
underrated yes but clearly legit
okay so I like the look wait I have to
have to calculate this to a win I like
the look of G6
I like the look of G6 because that that
opens things up and it threatens Bishop
H4
I think G6 is is where where the party's
at I'm just playing intuitively I didn't
calculate much but I mean this move is
not very high risk
and the main idea is we want to go
Bishop H4 and Chase The Rook away but
the Rook can't move because the Knight
will be lost
also very tempting was the move H6 but
then after 96 I wasn't sure how to
continue exactly maybe Knight H5 there
was also winning I don't know the G6
looks like the more textbook move
because it opens up the side of the
board where our opponent is weakest in
all seriousness there's no reason to
suspect anything our opponent's just
playing well that's all there is to it
Knight F6
okay so where should we go with our
Queen what's the best Square who can
tell me
where where should we go or should we
even move the queen should we maybe play
GH
in fact I think GH
is a great move because it opens up the
G6 square but I don't think we should
play it and I think we should keep our
options open
yeah Queen G5 is what I really like
because it keeps the X-ray on the other
night
it attacks the F6 Knight and it
sidesteps all of the Annoying
Shenanigans H6 is now a huge threat
yeah black is crumbling you can just
sense how our opponent is step by step
crumbling and the attack is reaching its
conclusion
H6 is going to be crushing on the next
move crushing
Knight H5 actually a good move I think
this is what black has to do but it's
not going to help
so here we should be disciplined because
there is a trap that's very easy to fall
into I noticed a while ago that our
Queen and our King are on the same file
you should always make a mental note to
yourself when that's the case just for
the future if you play Knight takes H5
and then Queen takes H5 black plays HG
and hopefully you see where this is
going if we recapture on G6 after Rook
to G7 we get pinned
and we get wind
so
let's see where how do we avoid losing
the G6 spawn I think what we should do
is just take on H7 first
to trade that pawn off
if King h8 then we have Knight G6 and
that wins The Rook on E7 we don't even
have to take the Knight
if King takes H7 then we can throw in a
check on G6 but I don't see the purpose
of that I think we should just take on
H5
and after Knight takes Knight we should
be totally winning we have the bishop
and the queen against two Rooks which is
a an overwhelming material advantage
takes on H5 the only thing to avoid is
after King to G8 to play Queen G6 check
this would be a very common blunder
again it would walk into the PIN so how
do we eradicate the pro this game is far
from over actually blackened black is is
very resilient and we still need to
demonstrate some accuracy
so King up the problem with King F1 is
that it walks out of one pin and into
another king F1 allows black to pin us
on the f-file and that walks into more
problems we should try to solve the
underlying issue which is that the
bishop is now the most passive piece and
the bishop should be brought if possible
back to E5 which is the square that
everything started with
so I don't see a reason for us not to
play Bishop G3 positive byproduct of
this move is that Rook G7 is no longer a
check so Queen takes E8 wins the game is
there a drawback to this move well yes
there is we've opened ourselves up to a
second rank check but it's not dangerous
it's not dangerous
but I actually think we we should play
not King H3 which is I think the
tempting move for most people
then we walk into potentially a third
rank pin and things get annoying I think
we should actually go back to F1 not
King F3 definitely not King F3 because
of rookie three check why allow that
I think we should go back to F1 it's a
scary move because you associate this
with the ladder mate but black has no
way to arrange his Rooks on like B2 and
A1 we're gonna cut him off long before
with the move Bishop to E5 so we're
gonna be first there
now Queen G6 check is now possible just
because a move doesn't work in one
position doesn't mean it doesn't work in
another now this move is crushing
because whichever way black goes he gets
pinned either King f8 Bishop D6 or King
h8 Bishop to E5 which is not mate but
force is black to give up at least one
of his Rooks it's over Rook G7 we take
on E8 and we've finally broken down our
opponents incredibly tenacious defense
major props to our opponent
we're playing
excellent chess Bishop B5 but this is
ding dong the wicked witch is dead
because actually Rook takes C5 would
afford black Sun chances were it not for
Queen F6 picking up the Rook
nice game yeah not without mistakes I
mean plenty of mistakes made by me
notice also that Rook G8 Queen H6 is a
Checkmate so black is literally
paralyzed and the e-pawn decides the
game
okay that's a good attempt a lot to
unpack here because this game
was complex complex I think we're going
to shift our Focus From the opening to
the middle game I mean one once the
course is released I will make a
separate YouTube video about it so I
don't just want to show you know the
course and stuff but I I wanted to make
a deviation from 1e4 just to say that
this is a worthy opening to have either
as your primary opening or as your sort
of secondary weapon that you could Trot
out from time to time when you get tired
of playing one E4
so Knight C3 Knight F6 and Bishop 2 F4 a
little bit of History the first time
that this particular
sequence of moose was played in the
database is let's take a look
I actually don't know that off the top
of my head
it was 19. no it was 1882 by James Mason
James Mason who was one of The
Originators of the London system which
is also known as the Mason variation I
think in the old school
James Mason played it in 1882. and then
Alexander alekine he played it several
times he was the fourth and fifth person
to play
to play the jabala London Alexander
alakyne he was so ahead of his time
but of course fast forward to the early
2000s to the mid-2000s jababa he plays
this extensively and to him we owe a lot
of the ideas that are now taken for
granted in this line a lot of them were
sort of pioneered by jababa report also
played this Richard report quite
consistently and several GMS have
contributed a lot to the understanding
of the theory of this line including
Bortnick with whom I'm working on the
bishop F4 course I don't want to delve
into too serious of an overview of the
lines because there are a lot of them
there's A6 there's E6 which is the most
common move on Lee chess there's Bishop
F5 which which was played in the game
the GM no of course bad or jabab is what
I'm referring to not his brother that
was fake news I think spread I don't
know where everybody got that idea but
it was definitely badur who
you know was the
you know Pioneer of this line so C5
there is E4 and this is a very sharp
line that you might have seen me play in
Blitz uh E4 is a pretty recent
Innovation before people would play E3
of course Knight C6 is one of the
appeals of this line at a lower level
because after Knight B5 white is not
winning that's a misconception but you
can win quickly if black doesn't find
the only way to Stave off Knight takes
C7 which is E5 like as to intercept the
diagonal and here actually you're
supposed to take with the bishop there's
one idea that's worth knowing and this
reoccurs several times in in the jababa
London which is that in this position
white has of course Queen takes D5 which
wins the second pawn and here you win a
third pawn and this is completely
winning this is a very important idea
now Knight C6 is not common but you will
not believe how many times I would play
E3 previously how many times Knight C6
has played in this position here Knight
B5 is just as strong with the
devastating threat of Knight C7 a lot of
people they end up going King D7 and
here you just hit the queen this is like
plus four black is busted here because
the knight's coming to E5 and you're
gonna open everything up this is one of
the most common sequences in the jababa
London and here after E5 you again take
with the bishop
and it's the same drill like 94 Queen 65
without the pawn on C7 but still totally
overwhelming
yeah I think the The jababa hoax does
stem from the recent controversy but I
think we can we are mature enough to
understand that
you know
someone might have acted inappropriately
but is still owed the credit for
generating the understanding of the line
capable of doing that
doesn't mean it's to rain in the line
so Knight C6 here is a mistake but after
A6 black equalizes this is one of the
equalizing lines and that is why E4 has
been the choice of most top GMS recently
including Hans Neiman who's done the
chessable course on the jabala London
anyways I'm getting carried away here
let's focus on the move that our
opponent played which is one of the most
popular responses we decided on E3 and
carried out the sort of main idea here
this looks like a totally symmetrical
position but there's a lot of Venom that
hides behind the surface one such source
of Venom is C5 very tempting move right
this is what you're taught to do now
Knight B5 is again very good black does
have Knight A6 so this doesn't come with
quite as big of an effect as it did
earlier but a position like this is
terrible for black because you're never
going to get the Knight off of B5 and
the Knight on A6 is a terrible piece it
has no Prospect this is like an improved
London system so for example Bishop E7 I
see the engine likes D take C5
obviously you can't take with a knight
you have to take with a bishop now
Knight B to D4 is very strong because it
opens up an attack on the bishop and if
the bishop moves back we deliver a nasty
check on A4 and you can see how nasty
this can get I mean black basically has
to go here and now you can take on A6 I
mean this is just bad 95 look at the
central domination that you have with
your pieces
so hopefully you can see already how
this line contains a lot of tricks and
traps it's important to remember that
Bishop B4 is not a scary move in the
jababa London you normally respond with
Bishop to D3 and you never fear this
Pawn structure because now you can play
C4 and you have the bishop pair
but most important to understand is that
Bishop takes Bishop is always met with
CD right controlling these key squares
and opening up a pathway for the queen
that's why the bishop comes out to D3 so
our opponent played the most common line
which is Bishop D6 95 and Knight B to D7
the danger of this line is well
illustrated by the move castles I
actually believe that I had a game here
in uh 2015 let me see if I can locate it
in the database it'll just take a minute
to run the search I think we were in
this specific position
and who can remind me oop I just had to
refresh because I got disconnected
who can remind me what White's best move
is in this position this is the whole
idea of putting the Knight on E5 what
does white do here and why is it
dangerous
so what's the move here
King E2 well
it's G4
now let's unpack for a second why G4
Works in this position
but does not work after Knight bd7 so G4
here first of all what is the idea of
playing G4 if black drops the bishop
back then it works like a charm because
white plays H4 I've got some very strong
GMS on this exact idea and I'll show an
example of that shortly white threatens
to trap Black's Bishop with H5 everybody
should see that h five Bishop before F3
and the bishop is fully trapped
now you usually you just play H6 and end
of story but now white takes on G6 and
this is the whole point by inducing H6
you're forcing black to completely ruin
his Pawn structure with FG and what
makes matters even worse is that you
could bring the queen out and
immediately start attacking the g-pawn
so black has to make this ugly move and
now he can't Castle or King F7 and now
the king is vulnerable and you could
really secure the G6 Square as an
outpost
again everybody should understand that
this is a very bad position for black
and tons of people fall for traps like
this unfortunately after G4 there is
Bishop takes E5
and if you take this bishop then it's
nothing special it's just you're just
down a pawn
I guess you can play Fe but this is an
ugly ugly position for a white now
White's the one with a ruined Pawn
structure
but if you play D E then there's Knight
takes G4 black wins a pawn and you might
say oh well I go Rook G1 and I have some
G file it no but you lose the pawn on E5
and blackened Castle Queen side
now compare that to this position what's
the key difference here black has
already committed the placement of his
King
so
if Bishop G6 then it works exactly the
same way you play H4 Etc H6 here
here actually what's funny is the engine
doesn't even give 96 the engine gives H5
and G5 mating this is just a mating
attack
but more importantly if Bishop takes C5
well what's the key difference you seem
to get the same position but it's not
the same position black is not attacking
the pawn on E5 which enables white to
play the move F3 and Chase the Knight to
the very very awkward H6 Square
second thing is that black has committed
the placement of his King so you can use
the G file to your advantage later the
engine gives H4 here to cover the H4
square and prevent Queen H4 by the way
Queen H4 here the bishop drops back to
G3 and the Knight is lost
so hopefully that makes sense so here
after Castle's G4 is very strong
and white gets a big initiative
our opponent played Knight b2d7 the game
that I referenced by the way was a
slightly different move order so I I
stand corrected let me find or let me
share with you that game you'll see the
similarity though you'll see what made
me think of it
this was 2016 not 2015.
and
so here I played F3 this game I played
the more traditional way which is early
F3 and G4 but hopefully now you're able
to see why the king Side Pawn storm can
be dangerous
and my opponent made a very instructive
mistake so we played this is all Theory
I got my knight to F4 and here he
decided that it wasn't a big deal to
allow Knight takes G6
in fact he gave this check on G3 which
looks very scary but my king is totally
fine being on D2 and I just continued
developing my pieces in fact the queen
is the one that is very vulnerable on G3
Queen E2 connecting the Rooks and the
game ends very very quickly he
exacerbates things with G5 I trade I get
my Rook into the attack and bang F4 G5
just crushing crushing attack
and what's funny is my king just hides
away on C1 when the time is right
and he gives another meaningless check
and the King ends up on B1 and it's mate
on h8
so F3 on move four is the main line this
is the most popular move and this is
worth investigating maybe we'll have
another game where I'll be able to play
it but hopefully that that illustrates
some of the the dangers of this opening
um Bishop D3 was the game continuation
our opponent traded and it really is a
shame that he blundered with C6 what's
hilarious is that the engine does
believe that Knight takes C6 is better
than Knight takes F7
because what I missed was that after
Queen C7 there is this additional move
Knight B5 notice how the knights control
the B4 and A5 squares there's no check
on before there's no check on A5 and
here of course this is just amazing
Knight D6 and Rook C1 and you have
you're overwhelmingly better and the
Knight is safe
so this was also possible
now black should have castled here and I
really believe that white is a little
bit better in this position
I truly believe that
white is better here because at least
practically because the Queen's coming
to B3
and black is cramped and a lot of people
they take on E5 they lose their patience
and this makes things even worse because
now the Knight has to drop back and
you've driven this big Pawn into E5 the
Knight is restricted black can try to
open things up but you're you're gonna
say I'm happy to open things up I'm
going to play E4 and at the end of the
the day white is I mean here white
simply wins with the Rook D1 opening up
winning the Knight on D7
so whichever way you you turn you get
for the unpleasant positions for black
I'm not claiming that this line leads to
an advantage but this particular
position is very uncomfortable for black
of course Knight takes E5 de gets forked
so that's another benefit C6 Knight
takes F7 and we solidify the extra point
so we're gonna fast forward a little bit
the next few moves I think were very uh
and I didn't find the game by the way it
didn't make the database but
uh so scratch that the next couple of
moves were very intuitive F4 improving
our position I explained this during the
game B4 to stop C5 A3 to protect the
pawn lift The Rook connect the Rooks on
the f-file this is all very
understandable and Bishop D6 saving the
bishop chasing the Knight away this is
where things got fun after we played E4
so Knight f8 is a good move we drop our
Bishop back so again E5 here allows
Knight F5 this and you've made backward
progress because Bishop C5 B6 and
already black is winning
because after you take the Knight
there's this intermediate move and hello
you know you've lost an exchange this is
bad
bad bad bad so we drop our Bishop back
to E5 and this is where we decided that
it was time to transform the boa
constrictor Advantage into a concrete
advantage and I played F5 the engine
seems to approve of it
now what I missed here was the move D
takes E4 this is a very interesting
moment who can tell me what white should
recapture with
counter-intuitive answer
it's not the queen no Queen takes E4 is
just bad so I know you're looking for a
counter-intuitive it is the night it is
the night to me this is counterintuitive
because your hand reaches for the pawn
right you want to keep your Pawn
structure intact but here black has a
crazy defensive idea Knight takes E5 de
and this pod on E5 is a Sitting Duck
which black can Target with Queen C7 I
saw this as soon as I played F5 I even
mentioned this during the game
and if black is able to win the pawn 95
black is fine you could try F6 but it
doesn't really produce that much effect
I mean if you push the pawn black
blockades it with the rook and it
becomes more of a weakness than a
strength
if you play FG which is maybe how white
should play I think this position is
still much better for white remember
that we were up a pawn so material is
now equal and the king is very weak this
would still be better for white by the
way nice trap Queen D4 Rook Cafe check
wins the queen or The Rook
uh so this would still be very very good
but the engine prefers Knight takes E4
and the idea is that we basically go for
D6 ef596 wins The Exchange and even
Knight F5 still
still Knight D6 because of the PIN
you're up in exchange I mean black can
go like this but a queen trade plays
squarely into White's hands
yeah Knight takes E4 is is a really hard
move to make actually
really hard move to make winning the
exchange always look for Forks right
queen of The Rook are unforkable squares
you should at least keep the D6 Square
in mind I don't know I would if I would
have found it he instead played e takes
F5 which I think is a mistake and here
it appears that I made a mistake Rook F4
is incredibly natural but apparently
Rook to G3 was more decisive
oh oh can I show my tactic yes I forgot
because that's why I don't write stuff
down instead of H3 let's rewind for a
second I was very tempted to play F5
here
and what I was trying to puzzle out is
after E5 whether we could play the move
F6 this is the move that really got my
got my attention
what is the what what is this move well
the general idea is that we're trying to
open up the f file because that's where
our Rooks are the Tactical justification
is that Knight F6 D5 is obviously bad
although it's not over apparently Knight
F6 the other way also loses to D5 and if
black takes with a pawn then we still
play D5
and after Knight takes E5 there is a
beautiful tactical move here I saw this
during the game
the simple line is Bishop E5 and Rook F6
and white is winning but if you want to
be clinical we play the immediate Rook
takes F6 simple tactic but very pretty
Knight F6 Bishop B5 and you win the
Knight with a decisive attack this is
over
why did I not go for this the reason is
that after GF D takes C5 there is an
incredibly annoying move that really
takes the air out of the building can
anybody spot this defensive move for
black it's really not an easy move and
it's not a move that you see this move
and you might be like I what's so
special about it the problem is that the
bishop is actually a big vulnerability
here it's not Queen H5 that's one move
it is easily deflected with Rook H3 it's
not F5 because that blunder is the pawn
remember we have two Rooks on the f-file
it's not King G7 that doesn't help
anything we can go Rook G3
it's not Rook f8 because that blunders
The Rook
it is Queen to E6 saisob got it and
dranus got it Queen E6
now this move is good on several levels
it gets out of the PIN
why is that important because now F
takes E5 becomes a possibility it wasn't
on the previous move the queen was
pinned
it also prevents e takes F6 because now
the bishop is dropped and and black
threatens mate
so it puts swindness in a very difficult
spot
okay you can play a move like H3 but now
black takes with the Knight and suddenly
black kind of consolidates
uh material is equal and white is still
better but it's nothing special
so
maybe our opponent would have missed
Queen E6 and so that is why I decided
now is not the time to cash in our chips
and decided to improve our position I
think this was a good decision I think
this was the right call
so anyways now we go to the moment when
I did play F5 we talked about D takes E4
now let's talk about this important
moment where I played Rook F4 honestly
missing queen to G6 which was an
annoying move I missed it
instead I should have played Rook to G3
and I missed something very simple this
is embarrassing I missed something very
very simple
I missed that after Knight takes F5 who
can spot the crushing move for what this
move ends the game immediately
but I just didn't see it I saw all of
the pins and stuff but I I didn't see
this move it's not Rook takes F5 that's
a very bad move Knight takes F5
it's tempting but very bad yeah well
even better is Bishop takes G7 check
this is the best move because if black
takes for the Knight then you win the
queen One Way Or you win the queen
another way if King GA this is a
hilarious position because taking the
Knight would be a huge blunder black
would take the rook and simultaneously
attack the queen and now Puck can block
of the queen this is equal
just shows you how treacherous these
positions are apparently here the best
move is to get the queen out of the
range of the Black Knight in order to
make Knight takes G3 impossible once
again now Black's position collapses
completely also you connect the queen to
The Rook so Queen to E1 is also winning
that's the secondary Point that's why
you don't play this move
right because here black can actually
still take on G3 and get two Rooks for
the queen
if black plays Knight takes G3 here then
you can recapture the Knight after that
Queen E5 is the second Queen E5 is a
tough move or queen E1 is even tougher
but this was winning on the spot Rook to
G3 because if Black Goes Rogue G8 then
F6 is CR I mean we don't have to talk
about this this is obviously crushing
the bishop on E5 because you just keep
the queen completely paralyzed
okay so Rook F4 I played and I allowed
Queen G6 this gives black a new lease on
life
97 but now Rook F6 we found probably not
the best movie but according to the
engine the patient no the patient Queen
E3 was the most accurate move and then
getting the Knight around into the
attack via H5 because black is so
paralyzed but I really couldn't resist
but I really couldn't resist
so takes takes and kudos to our opponent
for finding King G only move
obviously this is Checkmate this is also
Checkmate because the queen is pinned
there's just no other moves right
otherwise either Rook f8 or Rook G6 is
winning the queen but somehow this
escaped my mind
but again white is still winning because
the king is super weak our pieces are
still good and I'm really happy with the
move Bishop to G3 Moves Like These are
tough to play because you just sort of
admit that okay the game is going to go
on for a long time but you're using your
Pawn majority and at this point I
already had the feeling that the pawns
are going to decide the game
Bishop F6 was also possible but I was
afraid that the bishop would get
vulnerable on F6 so I think Bishop G3 is
very important move the queen push the
pawns this move should be totally
understandable rookie six keep pushing
now we get the Knight around to a better
Square to F4
and now we patch up the holes with
Bishop H4 G5 as a whole we need to patch
it up notice that Knight G5 threatens a
fork but that's just a one move threat
that can be easily parried with King G2
just something I pointed out during the
game okay we've got a few questions
nikino asks what about Rook G8 after
Queen E5 so sorry to keep jumping around
but to rewind
to that position after Queen E5
Rook G8 is not legal I assume you mean
Rook to E8 but now we play Bishop takes
H6 check and notice that this is a check
and Knight takes G3 you can actually
play Rook takes F7
and Rook G7 check and then recapture the
Knight
and it's still not over Blacklist Knight
F5 but we just win all of black spawns
here
yeah I got you so here we're just up 600
Pawns so notice that the G file check is
is winning second question why not
Knight takes F5
not sure where so you're gonna have to
clarify
so looks like that answers the questions
after Rook G3 so fast forward fast
forward we get the queen for two Rooks
okay we talked about Knight G5 yeah so
Rook E3 is a move that I think would
scare a lot of people but it doesn't
threaten anything and I think King G2
was a really nice move
because it it just eliminates possible
threats related to Knight F3 not easy to
trap The Rook here so our opponent
played Knight D7 we decided that now is
the time to push G5
and the reason I decided that initially
my idea was King F2
why is King F2 good I thought that we
could give the queen back for the two
Rooks no that's wrong not give up right
it's equal material and here I thought
that the pawn majority would decide the
game I thought we would have a winning
end game and it's risk-free
the problem is that King F2 puts the
King on a vulnerable square and Knight
H6 would be highly problematic here
what is the purpose of that move well
here black and play Knight takes G4 and
win the game as everybody should see
because you lose the queen
and I didn't see a suitable response to
that H6 that is actually why I played G5
to try to restrict this Knight the
drawback of G5
is that it yields blackby a five square
and he immediately went there but it's
just too late Bishop F2 and queen D1 I
think was a really nice move to get the
queen into the game so we just keep
accumulating and accumulating and
eventually Something's Gotta Give which
happens around here after G6 I think
it's already completely winning
according to the engine the only move
was Knight to E6 this is a very hard
move to play and it's plus two it's
still winning but it's not Elementary
uh G6 H6 we play Bishop H4 and we win
the game because black loses all of his
pieces so G6 was largely an intuitive
move
which should be understandable to
everybody H6 instead was proposed but
after 96 I feel like we're at a bit of a
dead end if you played G6 here that
would be a huge mistake because this is
a check and we just lose the pawn and we
lose our attack
so this here we would have to play
Knight H5 but things get the king would
be able to hide in the corner and I'm
not sure that this is the way to go
so I really think G6 is just more direct
and after Knight F6 Queen G5 the game is
over black has to give up one of his
Knights and the rest was pretty
straightforward
if black would have defended the Knight
with Rook f8 we would have taken on H7
Knight H7 blunders The Rook King H7
walks into a devastating Fork so the
lesson in this final stage of the game
is that you really shouldn't only be
looking for checkmate in these types of
positions you should really be looking
for ways to win material and I'm not
looking for ways to mate the king my
instinct is not Queen G6 Jack which
would be winning
but the best of King h8 is just to go
back it's actually to use the weakness
of the king to win material that's often
what happens your opponent gets so
bogged down with defense that he puts
his pieces on vulnerable squares and you
can win them with a simple fork or
discovery
yeah lots of tactics here so Knight H5
the last trap to avoid here was the far
less accurate Knight takes H5
because here black plays HG
and you can't take back because of Rook
G7 or by the way or black could go Rook
G7 and recapture with the Rook which is
probably even better to keep the g-file
open and that's squarely in Black's
favor so it was very important for us to
take on H7 first and now this eliminates
the whole uh all of these Shenanigans
and the final chain and this is the only
move which wins convincingly I'm
checking the engine without Bishop G3
black would have serious defensive
chances if he manages to keep the bishop
restricted so it's important not to
procrastinate and to immediately get the
bishop to its ideal square and King
drops back this is game over after Queen
G6 more resilient would have been Rook
to E6 but after Bishop E5 the game is
coming to an end because white simply
has too many threats here
uh so we went pretty fast through that
final stage of the game but hopefully
everything was relatively clear
are there any questions in that that's
basically it after Queen G6 check we win
one of Black's Rooks the rest is clear
without commentary
okay Furious has a question go ahead
this is your chance
yeah Caucasian Andy says yeah it is too
easy to go into mate mode and miss
looking for tactics this cannot be
emphasized enough really it cannot in my
opinion one of the most important
just sort of aspects of tactics and
attacking is the ability
to
not only look for
uh for mating sequences when the king is
weak to understand that you can other
tactics are still available they're
still on the menu so forks and pins and
stuff like that it should still be
looked for even when your primary goal
is is to deliver Checkmate I have a
great example of that let me finish with
that example
so I might have shown this before I
doesn't matter
so this position I was playing White
against a 2380 okay so obviously
obviously white has a huge attack
right but my opponent's last move was
Knight D7 to f8 which is a really good
defensive move
and well it defends against Queen H7
and the tempting Queen h8 actually sends
the king into the direction that it
wants to go anyway common mistake right
just meaningless check so I concluded
that I need to bring
I need to bring some beef into the
attack right I'm not going to win this
game with just the queen and the Rook so
I made it pretty obvious move E6 is
tempting because it threatens Maiden one
but black can just take on E6 this
doesn't do anything
right because black still has F7 Knight
F4 Knight F4 obviously G5 is not this is
not scary because you can just give a
check and stuff
so my opponent goes King F7 he runs and
here is where I spotted the tactic the
winning tactic so the tempting thing
would be just to look at the king but
tldr is that I was able to pay attention
to the placement of the pieces on the
other side of the board believe it or
not the placement of Black's Queen is
what loses him the game not the weakness
of the king if the queen was defended
and The Rook was defended then black
would still be very much alive does
anybody see the crushing tactic and what
it's based on it's not E6 E6 just Bishop
takes E6 doesn't do anything
it's Knight takes G6 very nice it is
Knight takes G6 and the main point well
if Knight G6 then it's easy you give a
check then you take the Knight and
you're just winning on the board
but what is the idea if black takes with
the King
this is where you have to not get bogged
down the Checkmate who can spot it
White's a plan win the game ends very
similarly to this
Queen H5 nice
and suddenly ef6 Dragon you win the
queen Queen on the other side of the
board
is lost no take the queen
what's hilarious is that if this hadn't
worked right if you didn't have that
tactic you have another way to win
you have another way to win which is to
go Queen G3 check and E6 this is what a
lot of people found when I gave them
this position you win The Rook but this
is far less convincing because obviously
the game continues here and blackened
orchestrates some shenanigans on the
queen side
so my opponent goes B3 he tries A
desperate play for counter attack abcb
and I go Queen H5 which is a really nice
move takes takes the king is on C2 but
it's not dangerous because it's easy to
see Queen a4check you just go B3 and
really notice the the the role of the
knights in this game they're amazing
Defenders because they control key
squares
the Knight on C1 is the hero of this
because it controls A2 controls B3 black
has no checks and white Massacre is the
king
yeah and obviously Bishop F5 check you
just take on F5 and you again go E6 so
my opponent he went Knight G6 and he
resigned after E6 check which wins wins
the Queen the game is decided by
combining the weakness of the king with
the vulnerable Queen yeah I have shown
this game before but it's worth showing
it again I think and I've got many other
illustrations of this but this is just a
hopefully this hammers home the point
all right and that concludes the
presentation folks
this was a longer stream than
anticipated hope you enjoyed the game
and the overview of the jababa London I
apologize for you know the deviation
look out for the course which I'll be
you know Shilling once it comes out
yeah I think this was a nice one all
right guys I am going to head to bed
commentary tomorrow
all right good night everybody see you
tomorrow morning for PCL
thanks again bye
[Music]